Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Before we start, I will tell you right away
to hold on to your papers.
When I’ve first seen the results I didn’t
do that and almost fell out of the chair.
Scientists at NVIDIA published an amazing
work not so long ago that was able to dream
up high-resolution images of imaginary celebrities.
It was a progressive technique, which means
that it started out with a low-fidelity image
and kept refining it, and over time, we found
ourselves with high-quality images of people
that don’t exist.
We also discussed in the previous episode
that the algorithm is able to learn the properties
and features of a human face and come up with
truly novel human beings.
There is true learning happening here, not
just copying the training set for these neural
networks.
This is an absolutely stellar research work,
and, for a moment, let’s imagine that we
are the art directors of a movie or a computer
game and we require that the algorithm synthesizes
more human faces for us.
Whenever I worked with artists in the industry,
I’ve learned that what artists often look
for beyond realism, is ... control.
Artists seek to conjure up new worlds, and
those new worlds require consistency and artistic
direction to suspend our disbelief.
So here’s a new piece of work from NVIDIA
with some killer new features to address this.
Killer feature number one.
It can combine different aspects of these
images.
Let’s have a look at an example over here.
The images above are the inputs, and we can
lock in several aspects of these images, for
instance, like gender, age, pose and more.
Then, we take a different image, this will
be the other source image, and the output
is these two images fused together.
Almost like style transfer or feature transfer
for human faces.
As a result, we are able to generate high-fidelity
images of human faces that are incredibly
lifelike, and, of course, none of these faces
are real.
How cool is that?
Absolutely amazing.
Killer feature number two.
We can also vary these parameters one by one,
and this way, we have a more fine-grained
artistic control over the outputs.
Killer feature number three: It can also perform
interpolation, which means that we have desirable
images A and B, and this would create intermediate
images between them.
As always, with this, the holy grail problem
is that each of the intermediate images have
to make sense and be realistic.
And just look at this.
It can morph one gender into the other, blend
hairstyles, colors, and in the meantime, the
facial features remain crisp and realistic.
I am out of words, this is absolutely incredible.
It kind of works on other datasets, for instance,
cars, bedrooms, and of course, you guessed
it right, … cats.
Now, interestingly, it also varies the background
behind the characters, which is a hallmark
of latent-space based techniques.
I wonder if and how this will be solved over
time.
We also published a paper not so long ago
that was about using learning algorithms to
synthesize, not human faces, but photorealistic
materials.
We introduced a neural renderer that was able
to perform a specialized version of a light
transport simulation in real time as well.
However, in the paper, we noted that the resolution
of the output images is limited by the on-board
video memory on the graphics card that is
being used and should improve over time as
new graphics cards are developed with more
memory.
And get this, a few days ago, folks at NVIDIA
reached out and said that they just released
an amazing new graphics card, the TITAN RTX
which has a ton of onboard memory, and would
be happy to send over one of those.
Now we can improve our work further.
A huge thank you for them for being so thoughtful,
and therefore, this episode has been been
kindly sponsored by NVIDIA.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!